there are several major stories we're
covering tonight Joe Biden being heckled
on the campaign trail and what is now
saying about testifying in the Senate
impeachment trial Plus liberal cities
blamed President Trump over the growing
homeless crisis but first a good guy
with a gun is being praised for
preventing a massacre in Texas the hero
stopping a government just seconds after
he opened fire in a church killing two
people local officials in the past are
saying the man saved countless lives we
can't prevent every incident we can't
prevent mental illness from occurring
and we can't prevent every crazy person
from calling again this church is a
model for that preparation we lost two
great men today but it could have been a
lot worse and I'm thankful that our
government has allowed us the
opportunity to protect ourselves the men
they're talking about is now speaking
out after springing into action I don't
see myself as a hero I see myself as
doing what needed to be done to take out
the evil threat at that point I didn't
have a clear shot those people were
standing up finally got about a second
later had a clear shot and I took the
shot the shooter went down since when do
you know when something bad is going to
happen you have to be prepared at all
times at all places and that's the way
that I strive that's the way that I
teach Maria I'll go to you this is
something that Republicans say all the
time that a good guy with a gun can stop
a bad guy with a gun and because of the
law that the Texas Legislature passed in
my home state Texas people are allowed
to carry in Turks they were already able
to do that but now they're able to
organize church group that are
volunteers to stop bad guys like that
what's that you in this situation
obviously this this man who stopped this
shooter from killing more people in the
hero this was a very good thing that he
was there that he was armed and he was
able to do this I for one don't want my
church to turn into a shootout I don't
want my place of worship where I go and
worship to possibly turn into a shootout
and this is not a solution long term for
the gun violence problem we have in this
country I don't think we should let this
one story which is a quite amazing story
we should point out let us take our eye
off of the ball in terms of what are
some common-sense solutions we should
have in this country universal
background checks including gun sales
not say we always need to have a
civilian armed by the way that doesn't
always end as well as it did here that
can be quite dangerous when you have a
lot of people with guns trying to figure
out who is actually the assailant and
who isn't this should not let us stand
in the way of doing actual common-sense
gun reforms despite the fact that this
is a quite amazing story
well Emily while Congress is trying to
figure it all out
average day people want to feel
protected and is this not enough cops to
protect us all so shouldn't we be asking
for more laws like this so people feel
protected yeah well first of all I think
to add to that kind of remarkable
quality about the situation you know
that law just passed in September it is
just a couple months old that enabled us
prisoners to have their carry concealed
inside and also obviously to waive fees
for the kind of security force that they
created and importantly I think the
state senator who co-sponsored the bill
said it best which is that there is no
such thing as a gun-free zone she said
evil people with evil intentions will
carry out their heinous acts regardless
of the legends
sation that is in place or that is not
in place and so in the interim I believe
yes those those laws that enable
law-abiding citizens to carry and
conceal to feel protected then that is
why we can prevent another situation
like this in which or that we can if it
comes to it recreate it in that in six
seconds that gunman was killed final
point to you know that that group the
volunteer security force for the church
they had been training for this and as
the person er stated you know they this
is their worst nightmare they don't want
it to have to come to fruition but this
is also not something that just
law-abiding citizens can pull out of
their sleeve this takes training this
takes that kind of preparation for these
horrible acts so that citizens could
stay safe and it's important to note
that this was a volunteer force if many
of you if you've seen the video they all
spring into action and you can clear it
will clearly see that they have training
there was no cross fryer there but Tom
what do you think about people you know
taking it the destiny in their own hands
there were no cops there this was just a
volunteer force a Patriots that decided
they just want to go to church and peace
and protect themselves yeah obviously
and looking at this guy I mean he's so
cool such a hero and he says I'm not
they always say that I'm not a hero but
I wouldn't mind this guy sitting next to
me in church I wouldn't mind him sitting
next to me at the office but we like
having guys like this around you know
what I call these guys first responders
mm-hmm and I say that I understand the
irony of that because first responders
we see them as the people who come in
they they get the tourniquets they get
the they have the plasma they have the
blood there's they're making people
who've been injured they're keeping them
alive well the first responders in this
case we're very glad that he was a first
first responder because there was less
carnage there for them to have to take
care of so you know they thanked that
him for that
so I the other thing I love is that the
fact we're seeing this guy's face all
over the news mm-hmm remember in the old
days when they always had the shooter a
bad guy yeah and they have the bad guy
in the front of the magazine and they
ever now we're not showing the shooters
as much I haven't even seen this shirt I
don't know what he looks like I'm sure
we're gonna see him you know and we will
see the face pop up in social media but
I would much rather see this guy then
the shooter on TV dr. suffer I mean
typically we talk about the politics
concerning guns and all this but there's
a simple fact here this was
mass shooting it could have been a lot
worse the guy had already wasn't
prepared to shoot more people but these
people sprung into action so doctors
like you wouldn't have to have a mass
crime scene or victims in a hospital
right you call me Nicole today by the
way farts so we're already seeing a
Polaroid polarized reaction to any sort
of shooting that we see and I get
concerned as to what's gonna come in the
next several days in the media we don't
know enough about this specific shooting
as of right now to know exactly what
happened but of the small things that we
have seen I get concerned on many levels
because you have the Democrats every
Democrat still in the race their gun
reform solutions potentially would not
have actually stopped this from
happening but what did stop this from
happening was the legally obtained
firearms and those that are protecting
the citizens there this gentleman who
that took out the attack he was arrested
in 2016 in New Jersey for illegally
possession of firearms so cory booker's
territory what happened there that was
your chance so I would like to know what
how did how did he get this shotgun
because he was arrested with a shotgun
in 2016 he's labeled as a transient so
these background checks would have would
have failed because he probably has this
legally at this point so the the ability
to be able to legally arm yourself and
protect really does help in a lot of
these situations because 75 percent of
firearms in mass shootings they're
legally obtained whether they are stolen
or not and so you have to be able to
protect yourself
amazing that criminals didn't follow the
law now to another horrific attack
federal prosecutors following hate crime
charges against a man accused of using a
machete to attack five people happen
Saturday night during a Hanukkah
celebration in New York City the FBI
revealing today that the man kept
journals filled with anti-semitic
statements but Democrats like New York
City Mayor Bill DeBlasio reacting by
blaming the president I also want us to
be clear what's happening here an
atmosphere of hate has been developing
in this country over the last few years
a lot of it is emanating from Washington
and it's having an effect on all the
weight sewing but we have to be clear we
need a different tone starting in
Washington Murray yeah
this guy is a clear black supremacist
hateful person crazy and decided and
President Trump is responsible I think a
couple of things are true here the first
is that it's not just an isolated
incident unfortunately we've seen a rise
in anti-semitic hate crimes here in New
York and also in other parts of the
country that's not all president Trump's
fault I also will say that a lot of
president is his fault I will say that a
lot of his rhetoric and him retweeting
right supremacist him encouraging
conspiracy theories on cue and on and
supported by people like David Duke like
this this allows some people who feel
anti-semitic feelings or her feel racist
feelings to feel like they have the
supporter in the White House his
comments after Charlottesville are
indicative of that doesn't mean it's his
fault but he should do better as I
believe it is the president anywhere
around this no I don't believe so I
think that oversimplifies the issue and
if I could bring up to that ancillary
issue of the the cash bail reform
happening here in the city because a lot
of the New York City Councilman brought
that up in their protestations of this
event and the rise in anti-semitic
events happening they basically said
look for the last two years we've been
begging for more law enforcement we've
been begging for coverage for security
cameras for etc we have been ignored at
every level and now we have the mayor
and the governor saying that something
needs to be done
meanwhile the same the same gentlemen
are now reforming bail so that 400 plus
crime divisions or divisions of crime
will have those defendants released on
no cash and no bond bail that is
literally 25,000 that have already been
released before the first and that's 90
percent of criminal cases including yeah
one of those women who committed those
crimes who punched two Jewish people in
the faith multiple times this is
absolutely a huge part of the problem
and quick distinction from New Jersey
which gives the judges themselves a bit
of discretion they can take into account
public safety like for example this
woman who committed that any sometta
crime in this state no holds barred Tom
the White House has an entire task force
against anti-semites I mean there's been
legislation sound the BDS movement has
been gone against is the president
responsible for that the answer is no
absolutely not and Bill de Blasio's
should resign I tell him to do this
every week he never listens to me he's
such an idiot
Cuomo is an idiot as well for saying
this
if anyone said this about a you know
Barack Obama
oh he's responsible for this of Moscow
it's so ridiculous but they continue to
get away with it because they have this
false narrative that Donald Trump is
responsible for this wave of hate in the
country isn't it's a completely untrue
real quickly we're missing one major
point here and that is that the person
who committed these crimes is a known
schizophrenic and let's remember Bill
DeBlasio was given one billion dollars
for his mental health campaign 12% of
which went to treating the mentally ill
the rest was a big PR campaign you have
to focus on mental illness anti-semitism
is rampant not just in the United States
in the world it is not the White House's
fault but this is a dual issue mentally
ill patients tend to hold conspiracies
theories and when they read about
something they really believe it he may
not have been bred to be an anti-semite
but he is an untreated schizophrenic who
when he reads things on social media and
media he's going to run with it
amen today